I'm Pete hegseth in for Laura Ingram
tonight and this is a special edition of
the Ingram angle
late last night speaker Kevin McCarthy
delivered a tour de force announcing in
very clear terms why he was removing
certain Democrats who deserved it namely
Adam Schiff and Eric swalwell from
serving on the Intel committee
the Intel committee's responsibilities
and National Security to America they
have failed in that place from Adam's
shift using a position of the Intel
chair lying to the American public again
and again swalwell
you all know does not have the or should
have the responsibility to serve on the
Intel committee well I'll put the
National Security ahead of partisan
politics any day Integrity matters and
we're going to make the Intel committee
back to what it was supposed to be
well today those aforementioned
Democrats held a press conference on
being booted it was a sad affair
alleging this was merely an act of
political retaliation by McCarthy in
other words they were basically owed
these positions well only I think breed
distrust within the intelligence
Community as to what it can share and
what it can feel confident about sharing
with the Congress our mission now is to
restore The credibility and integrity of
this institution of which the speaker
has so Gravely so Gravely smashed and
destroyed
so Gravely smashed not only do they have
no right to be on that committee and
were placed on other committees the
concerns over their misuse of
intelligence are extremely valid
Schiff who as Intel chairman had all the
evidence he needed
falsely claimed in a public memo that
the FBI did not abuse the fisa process
later the doj Inspector General released
the results of Zone investigation
exposing that memo as patently false
Schiff also played an integral role he
starred in a lot of films in claiming
that the contents of the hunter Biden
laptop were part of a Russian
disinformation campaign watch we know
that this whole smear on Joe Biden comes
from the Kremlin that's been clear for
well over a year now that they've been
pushing this false narrative about the
vice president and his son
look at Wolf Blitzer taking them
seriously we now know of course that was
a lie there's nothing in the laptop that
has been disproven
but of course that's not all
during the course of the January 6th
hearings so-called
Schiff was caught altering text messages
he altered them between Congressman Jim
Jordan and white house chief of staff
Mark Meadows
the committee was subsequently forced to
admit that the texts as it presented to
the public in a big made for TV moment
were false
oh and then there's Fang Fang's lover
Eric swalwell McCarthy's justification
for booting him well it's even more
Ironclad
he was compromised by a Chinese
intelligence operative that he also
happened to be sleeping with
the FBI was concerned about putting a
member of Congress on the Intel
committee because of his knowledge and
relationship with the Chinese spy Eric
swalwell would be in the private sector
and can't get a security clearance there
we are not going to provide him with the
secrets to America
so true we couldn't get one of the
private sector today at their pathetic
presser Schiff refused to address the
claims by McCarthy because they're true
while swalwell instead choose to level a
chose to level a bizarre threat to
McCarthy
we will not be quiet we're not going
away
I think he'll regret giving all three of
us more time on our hands
does swallow mean he'll have more time
to sleep with more Chinese spies
or does he mean he'll give up even more
American Secrets now both seem like
valid questions right hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else